this week's videos are sponsored by
manscaped and Shopify more on them after
the reaction [Music] people what is going on
there citizens of the reject Nation I am joined
by Aaron Alexander because today I have realized
every lady on the channel has seen hairspray but
not Aaron hi us two dudes are going to watch
hairspray today out of everyone here at the
channel we're not the pairing you would expect
for hair we're not the typical demographic but
that's okay that's I like musicals I'd like chick
flicks I don't even know if it's a chick flick I
don't know anything I know it's a musical that's
all I know well guys and girls leave a like on
this video also be sure to subscribe click the
notification Bell because we got a lot coming
out in December thank you to prepper for helping
us head it down these highlights thank you to all
who have joined our patreon page by becoming
super sexy reject that's where you can catch
the full length Reaction watch along where you
sync up with your own copy of hairspray and we
also cover several things over there exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs included Aaron
you ready I was B ready to sing and watch movies
that's the intro to me that we're going to sing
during this movie I'm maybe we should maybe
we should cover this together let get a little
[Music] notes where are we tell me now Suburbia
New York is this this New Jersey oh it's a period
piece right those look like old cars so I'm going
to say yes wow what a great opening establishing
shot ornette defies us bars I don't
know what that nword is what is that
what's that say I don't [Laughter] know
weird I'm starting to feel my my knees
grow [Music]
zun ah
[Music] yes join the composition so
far okay we got style we got Moxy all
right I'm going to love this movie
[Music] oh amen [Music]
sister baltim Baltimore that's where
we are I love the production design my
goodness the colors are [Music] great
great symmetry too we're popping looks
like a set interesting I mean it
is a set but think it was [Music]
intentional it's pretty
[Music]
fabulous that business hates [Laughter]
you Baltimore oh my god I've never heard a song
but it's catchy super catchy
oh that's topical you can say
that who is this actress I don't know
I've never seen her before she also is
the brightest outfit on the screen
everyone's like more muted around
her o get it oh you sexy lady you [Music] sassy
I like her walk it's got a
little dance mhm little strut to
it
[Laughter]
don't look how happy he is let that girl ride
my truck every day that girl so [Music] crazy
balore a this must in a good mood yeah this
is I feel jovial this all the joy this so
lovely Baltimore yeah you way to go Baltimore
woo Mount Everest is the most famous but not
the highest geographical point on this Earth
who can tell me what that is Heaven Excuse Me
Miss Whimsy I can't see the board again
Tracy turn blood Tracy turn blood if I
have to write you up for inappropriate hair
height one more time you will be removed to
detention hair can't just hang there like a
dead thing on your cheeks bars as I said it
is not Mount Everest now next week we I feel
another song coming on I Feel It In My Bones
back approxim 60 million years now if you turn
your pages so is the music like actually from
a py psychological standpoint from within her
like she's bored it's all in her head I think
it is nothing like we're to see other people
sing that' be [Music] interesting then Amanda
binds Amanda bind is in this I think that's her
right there oh [__] one minute to air I've
not seen Amanda bindes in Gears oh my Efron this
movie is insanely vibrant they should have shot
this on the volume what look is that Christopher
Walkin oh [__] it is this a studded cast James
Mars what the hell I didn't realize all these
people W it corny cin show teenage Baltimore
oh he is perfect for this era show are we
going to transition in Ultra clut really
cool he is a handsome
devil man when people would congregate around a
[Music]
television Yes
Yes Man James Marson and Zach Efron
together what what I'm
sorry this is the best movie
ever want to run that back real quick I thought
I heard it say nice white kids what is
this movie about Harris I'm Amber Brad
Tammy fenders Brenda sketch shell you
you're all good people I guess and I'm
L he got a whole Elvis Persona this is
live television for them yeah this is
what television is like in the musical world
every single show is a musical number my ears
are garbage cans would you turn that racket
down wait a minute yes this is the one that's
joh it's turning your brains in the mud Mrs
Tong it's a new dance oh that's cool casting
after he was in Greece now I wonder if like
on the stage if this is a role traditionally
played by a man as well or they just cast
him in this the movie version you Penny are
you trying to tell me that that Penny didn't get
permission from her mother to be here what Penny
Penny Penny you will never watch that show again
without that show I have nothing having nothing
bills we will be right back for some more of
that hot Detroit sound Michelle fer what's that
the cries of people being mugged H valma the kids
dig the rhythm and blues yeah they're kids corny
that's why we have to steer them in the white
Direction the white Direction dude I love this uh
yeah I really didn't know any of this was in the
movie that's it's a crazy fart this is great good
job dancing today it's time Amber what does he
have that a ring Amber Amber save your personal
life for the camera sweetie oh shiny white
people didn't invent the Blues do your job
my daughter wouldn't have to fight to be visible
I got to show some of the other kids once in a
while this time next year you could be wearing
an ill-fitting tuck snapping B mitz for photos
I don't know she doesn't she doesn't seem like
a good person I don't think she's a good person
show link this is nut she can't even dance I can
dance so much better than [Music] her Queen laifa
everybody's in this movie Tuesday of this month's
your rhythm Blues day negro day will be coming
your way so don't uh uh motor go back thank you
thank you wow you think this this movie is about
race I had no idea I really didn't I think it
might be about race guys seems like we'll have
an opening here on the show for a girl just as
fun loving but maybe not quite as free wheeling
cut school tomorrow and come down to Station Wy
to audition girl do it girl make him notice you
but why not why not daning is not your future one
day you're going to own Edna's ocidental laundry
stop projecting your fears onto your daughter
you want to be famous learn how to take blood
out of car pulst stre that's a skill you can
take right to the bank hey hey what's all this
Ro in here are they husband and wife I once had a
dream that I owned a coin operated laundermat and
I came down from that cloud real quickly I'll
tell you that mhm you tell your daughter you
don't pick people like crazy or girls like
us oh they're talking about the size she's
projecting her fears onto her daughter this
TV thing you really want it with all my heart
then you go for it this is American bab you got
to think big to be big big ain't the problem in
his family Wilbur nobody asked you I hope she
gets the job hope she gets it she deserves it
for a movie that has talked a lot about in the
last 10 minutes I I've only seen like one black
person something tells me more on the
way Amber look at this moly crew oh this town
sh has gone downhill since I was Crown Miss
Baltimore crabs my God how times have changed
these girls must be blind or completely dur
God I love Michelle Fifer when Baltimore Amber
that move is far too dirty mother wake up from
that dream of yours this isn't 1930 that
former star she's like a Disney princess
Disney villain princess oh totally I'm trying
to say Disney villain poor might still hold
some screwed
Judes see what you got twist twist twist twist
mashed potato Momo on my show you'll never find
a thrusting hip or bumping gr what's that a
dance for fleas and ticks oh you should have
seen my bag of tricks God they're [__] [Music]
Baltimore the costumes are to die for so bright
and vibrant are you scared we're on live no I'm
sure I can call well this show isn't broadcasting
cinemascope this one will never never get a date
in those hand me- down clothes kid she'll never
get a date till daddy buys her new nose OU would
you swim in an integrated pool I sure would I'm
all for integration it's the new frontier First
Impressions can be tough and when I saw you I
knew it if your size weren't enough your last
answer just blew it ouch so and stout you'll
never be in we're kicking you out per form and
your face this poor girl dang she's just getting
roasted over here you may go umow thank you poor
girl I think they secretly liked you there she
goes that's a [Music] line she's still optimistic
though still perky she is cutting my class Tracy
turnblad I trust it was something really important
I'll give her a break it should have been
gave her
detention what' I say what' I say I called
it black now this movie starting what you
looking at nothing not you damn come on
girl that's how I respond every time Aon
walks through that door now you don't what
does that dance a name oh this call it the
pton place after midnight I use it to attract
uh the opposite set it's working that is so
groovy spin spin my man yes use those hips
kind of like this hey hey oh [__] oh oh
girl get it oh oh girl hey I know
where I've seen you before where
corny show on negro day negro day is
the best I wish every day were negro
day yeah yeah hello my name is
sewe she's getting real what's
yours baby she's vibing I'm Trey
turn yeah she's found her
people are you one of us let's
go hey get
[Music] it I have no idea who this actress is
she's insanely charismatic she's really great
what's the ideas of March I mean how can a month
have an idea hold on come on is he a commentary on
Elvis culturally appropriating what she doing
with the Negroes Aaron you can't oh you you
can't I'm used to telling everyone else that
here Cor in the Hop tomorrow but if he saw you
dancing like that he'd put you on the show oh
yeah oh W sorry little darling hope I didn't
Venture do we're watching High School Musical
next Sor yeah this must be like mid 2000s he
still looks like teen Efron well don't you
hear him chime chime's not exactly how I'd put it
you feel my heartbeat whoa we're we're in 1950s
Baltimore you be careful about the touching my
uned when he tapped me and knocked me off my feet
oh is he is he an actual high school student
he's in this High School Musical Bricks now
he's like wow something about you
homie now he's going to start sing
about her cuz she she touched him
they're all smok walking a buch of
[Music] smoke the driver's [Music]
instructor I really feel like
it's storyboarded like that
had to really compose this film he mothers C but I
see oh God that was very sexual he was
just greasing his hair with his tongue
real slow like that's all the greasers did [Music]
it oh man you got to be with that
that black guy he was dry he can't
move like that he already got a girl well
clearly things aren't going well between
[Music] them y what's with the divided
lines in the pulse I don't know it's
like uh almost like it's like whites
and colored or something like that oh
you got to separate them okay yeah yeah it's like
laundry okay I'll go in front of you and it's
not about race it's just about products oh my
God is she going to defeat racism in this movie I
think she is she's going to bridge the gap want to
do pton place for corny you got to dance with
your CR and I got to dance with mine why it's
just the way it is Tracy but it's your dance is
she so unaware of the racism she touched a black
man time to get a bunch of attention yeah
girl go hips [Music] oh he can't take his
eyes off her oh he's getting turned on oh yeah
we're all getting turned on that boy frecked
up oh yeah this is this is Dam how expensive was
this movie 235 million why are
we watching thisy Mike where
isor and I'm
yay what a way to own oh my God she's the
full center of attention yeah she changed
her hair too and we just got to get black
people on television tell us about yourself
well I watch the corny Collin show and I
do absolutely nothing else we to think I
almost stopped her from reaching for the
stars now here she is on local daytime
TV and if you were president Tracy what would
your first official act be I'd make everyday negro
day what did she say dude we should get a shirt
that says that what negro day make every day every
day negro day yeah reject shop Nation [Laughter]
I want that chubby communist girl off the show let
me be the first to toss the Harpoon ouch first
we get rid of negro day finally some sense out
of you and we mix those kids in with the rest of
the council oo isn't this where it's all hidden
anyway now you can fight it or you can rock out to
it you can monetize it get some chocolate chips in
the cookie try face W cushion good choice wow
she's a product already oh at his [Music] shop
it's been a long time since I've seen a pure
musical where where it's like most of it is
the musical yeah very long time yeah I can agree
I think the last one I saw was in the Heights that
was a couple years ago that big little girl is
sending my sails through the roof more people are
breathing aerosol than oxygen think you could show
ooh it's the fifth it's fine just like smoking in
rooms is [Music] fine oh my God it's [Music]
begun oh my God they're just so much better
dancers oh sorry sorry I mess I missed
you I'm sorry I'm in a weird leg position
sir that's what we're talking about
they're just much better dancers if I
could take my brain and put it in their
body God that' be unstoppable there got to be
some program out you need to get [Laughter] out
oh let's go what I like about you damn okay
oh Wonder she' be liing out of Lollipop all
day we'll be right back with more negro day
brought to you by Napa away for stubborn hair
damn every Kink will be gone in a blank the back
oh how dare you pick the same song they wrote it
you watch yourself wow you are one inch from
being canell you know what your demographic is
cleaning ladies and Lawn jockeys ah just go
in a ditch somewhere hello is this the turn
residence yes Jerry Sandler Stiller I get I
get Ben and Adam mixed up all the time you're
racist you want Tracy to do what be a spokes
girl be a spokes girl I think she'd be perfect
tell me I get a free Captain perks like Captain
have to be negotiated maybe we should get you
an agent what voice is he doing Tracy I haven't
left this house in in years why we'll have your
father meet with him I I don't want to be seen
like this SE one I'll do it after my next diet
that's when I'll do it you see the neighbors
haven't seen me since I was a size 10 a ma
it's changing out there you'll like it people
who are different their time is coming that's
righty
she's a revolutionist [Music]
Aon she's plus-size and not a
racist she's a revolutionary
she's a Pioneer even I haven't
this house since 1951 [Music] a
You're So
Glamorous pregnant women smoking
and drinking that's right that's
progress that it's like a satire of the time
too it really feels like they took advantage
of translating a musical to film just the amount
of different locations they do and the amount of
different sets they have oh yeah no they they
definitely translated it very well in a way
that feels I don't know it it it captures the
stage Essence but you know it it lives in the
world of film as well it's very well done
very nice is this your older sister oh my
perhaps you'd like some complimentary cure now
if you'll just sign here no don't do it no I
want a non-exclusive contract and I want you
to absorb my 15% commission not a dime over
10 throw aier do you have any idea what this I
forgot I was asking what accent she he's doing
[Music]
balmorian you got to do B
atut at us where is there a team that's Happ
that's fabulous I let go go go of
the past now that joll does have a
blast it's like the
show [Music] a this look like it'
be so much fun to film yeah [Music]
man yay wait till Dad sees you sees me he never
notices what I'll wear in 20 years he never even
said to me nice Mumu or nothing wow really think
she's going to run into somebody she knows and
then she's going to get all self-conscious and go
back inside this is Amber and Mrs vont tussle Mrs
vont tussle is the station's manager oh damn John
F to Michelle Fifer that's cool let me guess Randy
dress yes well you'll stop traffic oh screw you
dude that is cruel you're awful don't you know
why she hates us she's afraid I'll be Amber from
his teenage hairspray really anybody can get grass
stains all over their back Amber stop it I'm sick
of you doing that just because she's a good dancer
I'm sorry you think that she can dance we know she
can dance what is going on back there Tracy that's
horrible Mr Flack does not have breasts I would
I would never so proud of herself perhaps you
like to share with the rest of the class Patrick
Henry's Immortal Last Words kiss my [Laughter]
ass you go you go be with
them yes learn some Rhythm
so the black people are always
in detention I guess [Laughter]
so not quite huh you put there for
the littlest things I guess having
a platter party tonight y'all want
to come check it out now would you
mind if I to checked it out she's also
in detention well would it be safe you
know for us calm down cracker boy what
was that expression Zach Arron just
made [Music] yeah but always have the yeah get
it damn who is this guy he's I no idea [Music]
too this is why you guys keep going
to attention cuz you just leave i s
they're in detention cuz they're always [Laughter]
[Music] dancing I can't wait to
buy this soundtrack or illegally
download it whichever one just like
streaming on [Laughter] [Music]
Spotify yo this dude's a real star
of this [Music] movie this guy's the
best and that is how she died honey reeling him
back in is the easiest thing in the world now
don't worry mommy will take care of everything
it's got like a Krill devill thing about her
does she oh totally she'd make a great K DeVille
old evil Hollywood Starlet mhm conquering [Music]
Baltimore That's The Equalizer right
there Aon the one and only there are
no other actors who go by that title looks
like y'all took a step out of bounds mama
wants you to meet my new friends this is just
so afrotastic you go girl I relate so much with
her my name is Mike Mike yes Mike Mike who
what the stuff dog what the hell right now
as we speak your daughter has entered
a hotbed of moral turpentine what that
I don't know I mean in trouble with someone
else maybe it's worth it I think no one use
the start of a pretty big adventure
Tracy edner turnblad just don't say
anything about People's race I mean you
don't have to rush off you know what I
do I'll left my iron on oh your AR what
I I can't get over that voice Aron on to
[Music] eat come on girl you know that sh
look good just dive head first come on is that
[Music] Brae is the proper terminology
soul food yes Greg it's soul food good
okay that's what I've cre food
you had chitlins [Laughter]
[Music] Greg how come in movies it's it's
always the black people who are so welcoming
to the white people that the white people are
always like black that's not the way real life
Works
[Applause] [Music]
y I'm glad Amanda binds is here she's
participating she is there to look at
things I got something for you yeah it's just in
you're going to love it oh cigarette oh it [__]
cigarettes that's nice what can I do you for
something for the mister sadly there is no Mister
at the moment be careful she's dangerous I do
need a fella the way to a man's heart is through
his his Funny Bone now here's a ice breaker for
you but what are you celebrating well it's kind
of an ending but it deserved to go out with a bang
what are we talking about the cutting you from the
show all right time y'all new how did that end off
screen we have had our last shows our little show
is a nice little placeholder the colored peoples
it wasn't getting ratings bull now I'll never get
a chance to be on the show oh and you will be seen
baby Zack AF must be so comfortable right now TR
black and white say never dance on TV together
if we can't dance maybe we should just March nah
let's dance I like the way you turn black Tracy
11:00 new what yall say slowly but sure should we
give this fine woman all great and she deserves
let's March are lovely people but if you protest
you'll be on lists you'll be un filed J Kover
will be still wi tapping your cold dead body
in the grave dude I mean what would you do say
what would I do if like the ones to March Yeah
March bro you getting March you know marching
march with us what if they fire me from Scream
seven if they fire you then I would quit because
I have other obligations just promised I could
sing at Miss Hairspray Pageant she invited agents
that's my shot tra I can't jeopardize that you son
of a [__] I just think this adventure is too
big for me oh God no no no no that's not right
I get it you're a baby he just called her huge
he called her obese to her face he hates her
because of her because of her size she hates her
size and he hates black people confirmed she's
crazy about you you have to say that you're
mother well I know a little something about
me
wa those lips those eyes that
oh my God it's a Grace [Music]
crossover do you think he really
wouldn't cheat on his wife with her I
think he's trying he's either extremely
oblivious or he's loyal as hell maybe
both your wife Ma you don't really believe this he
would do you never set him foot on that show again
wow the plan worked he didn't even do nothing damn
it's not fair it's not fair Tracy you know these
peers have never looked at another woman This
Heart only beats for size 60 60 wow and then
to just cancel negro day like that just to make
sure that nobody who's different she watch it
again except but every time they say negro they
would take a shot okay I like that people like
me are going to have to get up off their father's
laps and go out there and fight for it if there's
something you need to stand up for don't you
listen to old dogs like us Christopher Walkin
is always good to right in the line between
creepy and sweet and endearing like Gary Bucy
no not quite like John [Laughter]
Mal she just makes me feel old nonsense D yes
Styles keep a changing the worlds rearranging
but Edna You're Timeless to me a you're like
a fatal disease babe but there's no cure Sol
at this fever rage it's the classic walking
dance CZ when I need a lift time brings a gift
another day you you wouldn't expect him to be
a great singer but he is he's killing I don't
know if I've seen him seen in anything else
before you seen him seen before mhm I can't
stop eating your hairlines receding and
soon you'll have nothing at all this is
a story about acceptance Aaron it's beautiful
love and breaking the mold you'll never they
sing their way in Proms and sing their way to
Solutions sing your way to Solutions sing your
way out of phobias what a beautiful world
we're going to sing our way out of racism
too oh hell yes yeah looking [Music]
Foxy look at the different
eras yeah this is pretty
cool their Love Is Timeless and Spanish and
Spanish you'll always be first string You're
Timeless to me I like how the song they
chose for them matches sort of like the
period Association yeah it's very classic
more classic yeah with them and to call it
Timeless with these veteran actors wake
up everything's good again wiber what
happened you going to pay a heavy
price I know never dance on TV again
if I can't dance with seaweed and little
ANZ then I don't want to dance on TV at
all this girl just has such a good heart
I know I sto relating with her she's too
[Music]
perfect oh was a nice song Get It Queen cuz I
know where I you lead the March
you lead the March lead [Music]
him where's Amanda binds
looking a lollipop right [Music]
now integration not segregation
TV is black and white equalizer
let our children Dan Queen Latifa is The Equalizer
baby God damn the pipes God I had no
idea Queen Latifa could sing like this
I I love the how they kept this one simple
how it was just a March like it wasn't like
a bunch of choreography and everything oh
no let you absorb the the song itself yeah
stood on its own but I don't get what the
point of the song is to be honest with you
I know they're just saying words I don't
know I was like they're not dancing so I'm
bored just kind of went over my head I don't
know she went to pull out her daughter and
now she's at the front of the line by accident
you it's police learn to March properly I got
I got us good good job got us covered man don't
worry you and your little friends head back
to where you come from what do you mean little
excuse me she was talking to you Tracy no don't
do that all right boys let's take the whole lot
in you're kind of [Music] outnumbered just a bad
in in the merch you're going to leave right leave
let all your other girl black friends take the
fall for you maybe she's going to get a Gatlin
gun a Gatlin gun yeah yeah that'll solve it Miss
turnblad brutally attacked a sergeant with a blunt
instrument you see she going from turn black to
turn back I'm so sorry I'm proud of you you are
baby somebody had to do something these two
are so sweet bail for 20 is kind of pricey
you bailed all those people out upset with me
what do you mean those people you could go to
jail for helping me Tracy I'm already in jail
come on already in jail H it's poignant we get
the collard greens we could do some vegan mac and
cheese that would be great maybe you could live
down here I don't even know why we have this room
down here but there's food water first aid kit oh
my God the police are on their way things need to
change and I won't stop trying to change them good
you'll be waiting 20 to life get the jump rope
P don't you touch my can tuna lock in the safe
bunker I hope a missile drops on Baltimore
right now I hope she goes for the can tuna
first yeah maybe it's her it's the police Oh
I thought you'd be Tracy a fron I was just at
home uh practicing my new Twist on the twist I
overheard it on the news I can't believe Tracy
savagely bludgeoned an eagle scout I should have
been there beside her I can't sleep I can't eat
did you hear that teenage hairspray you are
absolutely positively permanently punished you
will never leave this room again I hope she gets
at least one song in this movie you think she's
religious in real life hey just the man we're
looking for I'm here to rescue the fair made
baby know while she's up this is
hot myself on the outside I looked [Music]
good I hope he just keeps
finding more food all half
eaten she's into the knives okay
confirmed [Music] she girl that's
right that's my greatest fear that's my [Laughter]
[Music] wife's yeah damn he's really
passionate in the way he like kisses
her and stuff and everything as it should [Music]
[Music] be music all over is
awesome I love when they keep the comedy [Music]
going she like what the is going on in my
record store why you ain't think of that
before what you think she done for us where
your man is at boy I don't know I don't know
got a girlfriend and now shut up you Oh So
This is Love What is love baby it don't hurt
me you two better brace yourselves for
a whole lot of ugly coming at you from
a NeverEnding parade of stupid so you met my
mom how insanely subdude manes in this she's
so so passive oh yeah she's literally the
support character in every I need every way
of the word turn your face this way the other
way everybody oh my God teenage hairspray p is
about to begin I once saw Amanda bin in person
though yeah yeah instead of what I like about
you so it's a story about getting
black people people on TV and self
acceptance we're getting the world
to accept you too the agents are
here they look like Secret Service agents
there's no sign of her we're on every door
she's not inside doesn't mean she won't try
valma I seriously doubt this girl is going
to risk incarceration to win a pageant you
don't know her you don't know this [Applause]
girl that's a lot of hairspray how are
you breathing right now I used to use
hairspray did you really W I don't like
the way it feels I feel like it's you
know for just something tells me it's
just not good for you just I don't know
are they spraying real hairspray yeah
oh Jesus and now for the talent portion
of our competition our counet in their Miss
teenage hairspray official dance off oh ouch
damn [Music] they just need to
throw a bunch of black people
on that stage don't they they're hidden in
the audience launch them in them like like
t-shirts confirmed sighting what you
[Music] drink it's a distraction Aon it's a
[Music] distraction oh my God what
if she's already in the building
what what if she's been here for hours
that's one more Point [Laughter] Greg a
giant hairspray bottle put your back in it
then put your backs in it this time sneak
faster that's right Christopher it's with you
people I mean how hard is it to beat down a door
that hairspray battering ram was heavy heavy how
could it be heavy they're inside of it uh wow what
a crazy crazy plan you got to get her you got to
depend on them using the hairspray bottle to break
down the door got to admire the creativity that's
like some Lex Luther [__] right there some Baron
Zemo [__] some some Lex Luther BBS Ultimate
Edition [Music] [__] I so unimpressed but even
if Tracy wi she'll still go to jail for beating
the [__] out of that police officer true maybe
they'll be so inspired she'll be acquitted of all
charges or she'll sing her way out of an arrest so
how we resolve conflict in this movie the final
tally it is my obligation to announce that Amber
Von tuss is about to get out dance Tracy turnl
look how excited he was she get rid of the be
[Music] yeah
[Music] Tracy he's in love with her
yeah Proclaim Your [Music] Love ah yes yes
you savior
them you white
save Efron use white [Laughter] [Music] save
oh [Music] damn damn these two turned
me on so much the sexual chemistry is
crazy I really feel like they're really
attracted to each other oh yeah people
believe the most must have happened
all set with these that's [Music]
real wow yes break the and the new this hair spray
is that was cool that was unexpected she deserve
[Music] that they defeated racism yes one dance
number at a time see I told you what's the point
of marching you have to dance you have to dance
she's not even a candidate she just got a Title
Wave of calls Velma well anyone who dances for it
is eligible rule 30 paragraph 5 estri down at the
B [Music] okay oh oh oh she got oh ttch it twitch
who's twitch the dancer who was like he's huge
he's big on Tik Tok So You Think You Can Dance he
I'll tell you later I'll tell you about it later
I switch the damn tallies small you're uncanny
camera oh my God can't see her face she's so white
bir do it now or forever wish you get on [Music]
there
wow I Ro just so embraced the [__] out of this I
love it so much Corney do something
the show is turning to gumbo damn
straight is turning to gumbo this is the
future that's right that's this is your
time the activate white safe
D what an epic finale God
damn I can learn this choreography I believe
in you you can't stop the I already know
it to my [Laughter] blood
woo cut away immediately okay they're back
no you need at least 6 months to get over
your [Laughter] ex-girlfriend
you can do that now with better
[Applause] help is it over yeah it's
over directed and choreographed by the
same person I've ever seen that before W that's
cool Leslie Dixon dude we defeated racism we did
and uh um obes ISM obesity and racism in one
movie Let's Go I need to wash my hands that's
okay how lovely that was really lovely that
was really lovely you know what's even more
lovely though what's more lovely Greg when when
companies want to support the the Channel when
you're likely to not have your video monetized
due to the amount of music that plays in a video
thank you to Shopify for sponsoring which is what
we use for our merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in e-commerce so whether you're launching
a passion project or scaling to new heights
Shopify is e-commerce Powerhouse guiding you at
every step from creating your first online store
to opening physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're selling
exclusive merch or unique Collectibles thanks to
their all-encompassing platform for both online
and inore sales their checkout system unmatched
it's 36% more effective at converting visitors
into buyers than other platforms and let's not
forget Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but seriously
reflecting on our journey using Shopify for www.
reation shop.com it's been transformative the
transition smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying sales
to scaling our offerings Shopify has been
a Cornerstone of our success and Shopify isn't
just for us empowers 10% of us e-commerce backing
businesses big and small in over 175 countries
their are war-winning support always there
to guide you so ready to join the revolution
sign up for Shopify at only a dollar a month
at shopify.com rejects all overc case shopify.com
rejects start your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team Mary bsmith reject
Nation you know what the funny thing is I already
owned this product before agreeing to do this
partnership I could have used my influencer ring
to get it for free right at a discount but hey now
you can get it at a discount cuz this week we are
of course sponsored by manscaped as a married man
who's always on the move I value looking sharp all
keeping things efficient that's where manscapes
performance package 5.0 Ultra comes in featuring
the lawnmower 5.0 and it is a game changer the
package is honestly a perfect gift for yourself
or for another man that you might know I'll give
this to John if anyone ask I pay for it out of
my own pocket but no seriously this is easily
the best because it comes with not one but two
NextGen blade heads see the difference it's good
thing I have two now for demonstration purposes
so you got the standard trimmer for a perfect
neat trim but this one the new foil blade for
that super smooth finish and oh yeah it's all
about safe grouping with their Advanced Skin
safe technology plus they're waterproof so no more
crumbs on the carpet the package also encloses a
WeedWacker 2.0 for ear and nose and I definitely
use this because look at me I'm a hairy guy and
the must have liquid formations the crop sother
aftershave lotion and the crop preserver ball
deodorant say goodbye to poet of irritation and
hello freshness and the ultimate Cher on top two
free gifts manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and the
[__] 2.0 toiletry bag again I already have one
the boxers I'm wearing my here right now and the
bag is perfect for all your grooming Essentials as
you can see so you ready to elevate your grooming
game head to manscape.com and use code rejects for
a cool 20% off plus free shipping remember it's
rejects for 20% off at manscape.com let's get
those jingle balls holiday ready with manscape
okay so we got the credits rolling Aaron please
my friend who I did not intentionally bring here
because he's black a racial mie we almost watched
city of God which would have been way more on the
nose I think I don't know anything about it um I
saw I think I saw black people in the the cover
the cover I don't even know what that movie is
I don't know what it is either but I was like n
let's watch hairspray and I'm sure this will be
a nice fun time wow with no social commentary
whatsoever uh I enjoyed this movie it was fun
it was a lot of fun the the music was catchy the
dancing was incredible the sets were awesome all
the acting was really good the lead girl is super
Charming everybody just [__] freaking killed it
I can't say the FW maybe at this point in the
video I can but uh yeah I thoroughly enjoyed
it I thought that there's such diversity in the
types of music we saw in the movie I thought the
performance especially I think it I guess Fray
credits it was an ' 80s movie first and then a a
stage play in 2002 really yeah just by the order
of what the credit said oh fascinating okay oh I
would have thought this came out in like 19 um
came out like the mid 2000s this version of it
anyway oh yeah I thought this this play came out
in 1962 exactly huh no wait oh no it came out in
the 80s you said the movie came came apparently
there was an ' 80s movie you would have thought
it came out in the 60s I me said I'm just joking
I was saying that I thought the the stage play
would have come first that would makees sense
but uh I guess not maybe okay maybe they made
the movie then the movie inspired the play and
then it's one of those situations where the
play version inspired the new iteration of the
movie right right right right right that could
be a thing okay that happens sometimes let's
watch the original one now let's do it back
to back compare compare back Tob back I mean
like this is the exact same movie there's not
a creative bone in this movie spot but this
time we're taking shots every time they say
negro day oh yeah and I'll chant it three times
every time I can get away with it and I'll give
you a look which you don't know if it's approval
or disapproval but I mean look yeah that's just
a fear in me it's okay it's how I respond it's
okay you either gain a lot of respect or get a
lot of haters either way um but what you not like
about it uh only two things only two things but
doesn't take away from the rest of the review
I think that there are moments I think just a
causality of like just musicals in general
where there were like moments or beats that
were like skipped over for the sake of the plot
like for the the fact that uh they didn't they
got cancelled or their negro day got canceled
off screen we didn't even see like the process
of that and then uh there's one other thing that
that happened off screen that I was like oh this
has happened a little fast um well I get what
you're getting out because things get resolved
quickly very quickly like there'll be a moment
of tension or conflict and then resolution can
kind of come the time it was the most prolonged
was the whole thing with um the cancellation I
can't say the word right you say black day it's
a black day African American day what about g day
Monarch says that referring to Godzilla nope
that sounds offensive in some now say end day
say they say any day they they cancelled
uh the the black people's day there you
go you can say that but I really want to say the
word I'll pay you money you let me say it man my
hostile moment right here it's like 50 cents for
everything yeah but no yeah I I think yeah this
the causality of of it being a musical because
there uh they want to make this this experience
that's both fun that has this plot carry the
music that they're trying to do but in that some
of the character moments uh both plot-wise as far
as like how they progress and individual character
moments are kind of sacrificed because of that I
think that's just the causality of just the kind
of story we're watching but overall I enjoyed it
I had a lot of fun with it I can't say it's my
favorite musical but it's definitely a really
enjoyable one there's like a number of songs I can
think of like Baltimore was really great the You
Can't Stop the Beat at the end was really great
um who's that guy you said was there twitch so
he was a dancer he's like a really famous dancer
uh that he was on like So You Think You Can Dance
he was like really big with his family on uh
on what's the app the clock app Tik Tok and uh
yeah he was like he like did a lot of stuff for
like the community for like younger dancers and
stuff and then either I think it was either late
last year or early this year uh he kind of unived
himself so oh did he yeah yeah yeah it was a big
thing um but um yeah he's a really good guy he's
really uh positive and really impactful on uh both
ansers and just like young black people yeah yeah
he was a good guy but it was cool to see him pop
up in this movie I I liked his little Cameo uh
but yeah man I I I liked it overall man what you
think I liked it quite a bit uh I thought it was
really fun and I I obviously have no idea what
the 80s version is like or the 2000 simp I have
no had no idea what this movie was even about um
I expected a period piece just due to some of the
images that I had seen and I really I thought it
was like some of things just going to be a little
repetitive from what we said during the reaction
vibrant colorful um full of charming Charisma just
laced her out every performer gave their aame even
for someone like Amanda bind she really knew her
role just like there's something so funny about
how simple of a character she is like it's it's
not like um I don't want to I want to make sure I
phrase this properly cuz I don't want it to sound
like I'm justifying something here cuz it's not to
me I feel like it was super intentional of how her
character like just this like completely kind of
Airhead dry um type of performance that I thought
was really really funny and and uh but yeah our
main our main character lead was uh amazing as
well John TR vure too joh great yeah took me a
while to get lost in it like I I would be I was
really aware almost every time they cut back to
John Travolta that it was John Travolta oh yeah
I never I don't think I ever stopped seeing John
Travolta I was just like okay I accepted that this
is John Travolta playing this mother and he's
like I think that's part of the fun though yeah
is like knowing it's John Travolta that's like
you you need a bit of that awareness like you
you never stop seeing his face but I feel like he
does a good job with his mannerisms of portraying
that this is a woman who's like a recluse who
has like a lot of fear and uh and well I self
not deprecation what's the word um insecurities
yeah I think what helps is he's so committed to
it and not in a way that's like I'm playing the
joke of I'm a guy in a in a in a in a big suit
and I'm a woman you know he's not like Eddie
Murphy and it or something you know he's he's
just really committed to the car and because
of his commitment uh even if you're like even
if you still see John cholta it works yeah like
within the context of the film so I thought he was
great I think I I think Michelle feifer was very
effective as the villain of the movie I thought
she was excellent the costumes were gorgeous and
the choreography it's it's fun to see a musical
where a lot of the times what I really liked about
it was that it felt like a film you know and and
granted it's like based off of a it's a remake of
a 80s movie but what I what I really loved is you
know seeing that it was directed and choreographed
by the same person uh was really interesting to
me because this could have easily been something
where it relies so much on just the performances
and the choreography yeah but the movie's really
directed like there's so many shots in this film
and the editing is kind of FL Flawless and the
way they capture the musical sequences there's
such great variety of musical numbers and uh I I
was I was so impressed by just how composed every
musical number was that it wasn't just relying
on performers singing and dancing and getting
a few shots like there was so much effort put
into directing the [__] out of this movie you
know and and I love that and you get this like
really cathartic epic finale but I do I would I
would agree with you though that like yeah I mean
it's it's long uh it feels long you know and maybe
we're more aware of the time just because of the
kind of day we've had but you know so it's under
two hours technically but yeah yeah you start to
feel a little bit towards the end yeah but but
when you do get to finale you're like this is
a really great finale it's fun I was there was
never a moment where wasn't wasn't enjoying that
final song but I did find myself kind of craving a
bit more I guess the word is like sitting with the
tension and really feeling it at times instead of
like getting result because it took a while for
like tension to really kick in it was like a 40
minute Mark and and I think you kind of need some
of that like the actual main plot to feel some of
the drama you know and let some of those moments
breathe a little bit more yeah but it's musical so
you're often getting swept up in musical numbers
and maybe that's not where you're really going to
get like my favorite kind of musicals are are the
ones that that can be um uh go in and out that can
really go in and out a little bit more often and
and really experience the drama of the scenes when
there's not a musical number happening do you
see a tick Tick boom I have not that's a great
I've heard that's a great musical yeah yeah um I
haven't seen that one but uh as it stands I mean
I think it's a pretty gr it's a grandiose It's
a grand Larger than Life film and you know the
message is pretty uh simple don't be racist don't
be racist don't be a Prejudice towards people of
of other body sizes I did like that because we've
seen a lot of movies there's a lot of movies out
there about like defeating racism and while that's
a message that for some reason needs to constantly
be driven home to even to this day uh to when
dealing with body images in the same movie I'm
like oh that's actually something I've never even
really thought about it Ander to be like who you
put on TV right and and to be accepting of that
and to embrace all types uh I thought was a really
really really neat thing to do like a duel of of
both of those actually in one movie yeah I thought
it was interesting because it started off about
her about uh Tracy and her uh being perceived
as not being worthy to be someone on TV because
of her body size and then there were there were
like the the seeds planted in about negro day like
in the beginning and felt like it was going to be
her overcoming this this whole journey of like
how she's perceived in the world and how that
affects her generally oh they made a a musical
too I mean a a live version interesting uh but
yeah then it it turned into this larger thing of
inclusion not only with people of altering body
sizes but of race as well and I think once we got
to see the aspects of race that's when like the
thing really like kind of carried off and I think
if we would have gotten a little bit more moments
to breathe or a little bit more of the tension of
that kind of like how you were saying I think it
would have been like a heightened experience but
I think maybe that's just how the musical is on
its own but yeah like I thought that that number
where they were all walking through the street was
really good you know it wasn't really about the
dances about the performance it was about this
moment this this act that they're doing in solid
day or one another because they are experiencing
an injustice so yeah yeah also the the variety
of music was really great from the music number
musical number we saw with uh m not Michelle Fifer
what's her name Britney Snow not Britney Snow did
you say Britney Snow is that is that who it was
no the the classic song with Christopher Walkin
and with uh John jolta and that song versus like
the more traditional kind of stuff with Baltimore
that like feels like very Musical theery and then
we had uh the song where they're walking through
the street that feels like very Just Like Old
School very very much rooted in in Black Culture
and and uh go Queen Latifa song Queen Latifa was
also great in the movie as well I thought she
absolutely murdered her performance and I also
like the satire like there's a lot satire yeah
satire yeah there's some good satire in it there
was a great satire when they make fun of the 60s
I thought that was really fun the I like the scene
where um it's it's what's her name's number it's a
John tr's number and she's going out and like the
exaggerated like there all the kids in the car and
then like the the pregnant ladies what you were
talking cuz I first thought that's what you were
talking about so that's what made me remember
that was that the movie has really funny satire
yeah no it's it hey this this rot and tomatoes has
now also as I've been wanted to compare the rot
and tomatoes both both the movies have incredible
audience in critic scor the the 2007 that's when
this came out 2007 yeah um but yeah like the Eddie
Murphy comparison someone else also said that he
attempts at a fat female it's gone wow someone
said when Blonsky dances it's embarrassing that's
really mean she was like the best part of the
movie boo who is that that black guy Amanda bindes
was into cuz he great he was excellent Superstar
I'm surpris I have a theory that the the main
girl she's so charismatic and such a life and such
energy in this movie I have a feeling she's more
of a theater actress and they got someone from
the stage he' be the lead of the that would make
a lot more sense Elijah Kelly Elijah I feel like
he's probably a theater actor too okay let's see
what has she been in so far a lot it's uh IMDb
the chick oh I guess yeah this are movies right
here huh not a ton I have no idea what any of this
what a huge gap between 2023 in 2013 she didn't do
anything for like 10 years I guess one thing in
2017 Dam mag TV all right let's look up Elijah
Kelly I feel like a lot of these guys are um
theater actors yeah yeah oh he was in the butler I
haven't seen the butler I've never seen the butler
either what oh dude that's perfect for for us as
as just friends yeah as friends as buddies as just
friends nothing nothing else nothing reason we'll
wear our negro Day t-shirts to the movie does that
have to do does that have to do with black people
what blind people black I think so you ever seen
Ray you want to watch the movie Ray with uh with
Jamie Fox the Ray Charles yeah Ray Charles I know
that movie really well they taught me that racism
exists yeah you haven't seen it I have seen it
it's a great movie we should watch it again I'll
watch you watching the movie okay yeah what about
Roots seen Roots uh no I have not seen roots I
haven't seen Roots either that be a fun one that
sounds like a really fun reaction right there oh
jeno and chained you watch jeno and chained of
course have you not no I love that movie it's one
of my favorite movies all time dude you got be so
excited I was like Now's the Time views remember
seen the Kill Bills though yeah I had someone for
you and they done messed it up oh they watched
them lame boo hre Gordon oh now he's stuck with
just watching Jewish movies movies here gosh dang
it anyway Jackie Brown never seen Jackie Brown
oh that has a black person it does there a few of
them there's a couple in there
actually hey man sometimes you make enough of
these racist satire jokes and people are like
that's funny and then once in a while people
will just come at you happen to day did it
really on some old ass video of mine that I saw a
comment on what yeah from years ago they were like
that was I know you think you're funny but that
was kind of racist and I'm like hey man law of
averages it's funny and then once in a while like
whoa that sounds racist you made like hundreds of
videos you still just got get alert for all the
people that comment on your videos yeah it was
some patreon video oh okay so it might have been
really bad wof cuz I could be more edgy there I
kind of want to see it now I didn't even click
on it I want know what you said oh what were we
going to say about this they said they said like
I'm Asian and that's like and I know you think
you're funny but that's kind of that's racist but
if you makeing like an asan you can get a pass
because you're asan and that's what I said I said
like this is an old video and I'm Asian that's
all I said there you go you get the pass yeah so
I'm like what's up that's that's selflove right
there how dare they yeah how dare they presuming
now let me tell you a black joke lady is what I
you oh you're G to tell me that Christopher Watkin
uh sang He's sanging something you didn't ever see
that music I actually don't know if he sings in
it but there was that music video it was like a
really famous one I was worried it was going to
be like a famous movie that I never knew about I
don't actually I've like seen stuff of him singing
I was always aware but now I couldn't even call
the hand uh I couldn't even okay there was one
like famous M The Fat Boy Slim one is a huge is
a huge one where he's just it's just him dancing
the whole time what is this I've never heard of
that before you've never seen the Fat Boy Slim one
no I've never heard that it's great it's just him
dancing that's awesome he's got like a I I was
aware that he has like a theater background so
that's I think I just knew that he sings oh for
sure and I've like heard like bits but I didn't
I can't tell you like yeah he he sings This and
That 72 million views dude no it's just like it's
a great video I've seen it a bunch it's just him
dancing the whole time just Christopher walking
dancing for three three minutes and 45 seconds
it's a really good video clearly the man's got
it the man's got the skill um but yeah in this
movie overall hairspray I would give it like
um I just think for like the amount of creativity
and from what I can see from the raw and tomatoes
comparisons it's not just a shot for shot remake
or I think they even create some songs for it oh
wow um from what I can see and it's and it's
funny too the movie is funny it's really funny
it's fun and I think the movie the movie movie
when it Embraces the com I think there's some
very creative visual gags in here yeah and when
they Embrace that I think it's really effective
so while like while the message is nice I wasn't
like super moved by the message or something I'm
more like this is a fun movie fun songs and
with great performances uh I I think just for
film making like that was really I give it like a
like a n out of 10 Ju Just for that uh alone give
the film the film making or the film n out of 10
I think think my overall film experience is like
an eight out of 10 okay um I probably go 7.5 okay
yeah yeah but I I I boost it up because I'm like
this took a lot of I think I think there's a lot
of creativity in this movie and and I give it for
the credit and knowing just how long it having
a a basic understanding of it takes forever to
set up one shot yeah and then to see just how
much Ingenuity they put into like every every
single scene where it didn't feel like a mess
it still flowed the entire time in a smooth way
I was I was delighted by that but yeah there was
something a bit missing for me so yeah I've seen
other mov musicals that have moved me never had
that like that heart like wrenching or that that
heart grabbing number within the movie you know
I think they they for the most part kept it like
on the lighter side with their with their stuff
but yeah I do agree with you in the sense that
it was like a movie you tell that was directed
really well and like the shots look like they're
really well composed and like the way that the
they shot the music just felt very energetic the
whole movie felt alive like you can tell a movie
where like it's just very static and they don't
care but they really you can really tell the
love and care put into this film both within
the performances and behind the scenes so yeah
I would say overall was a 7.5 because it didn't
I feel like the the themes they touched on both
with the stuff with like the weight and the food
and the black experience I think something I can
identify with personally but I think for both of
those things being in this movie it could have hit
harder me what crazy who would have thought uh but
yeah I thought fight with the white people that's
right uh I yeah give it a 7.5 and yeah it was fun
a good time yeah man uh what did you guys think of
hairspray what's your favorite musical number here
what's your favorite musical leave your thoughts
down below um be sure to subscribe leave a like
and uh hey we'll catch you all soon peace
out reject Nation peace out peace [Music] out